brought to you by PlayStation view the
new live TV service now available on
your playstation over 100 channels no
annual contract game the system hey
folks Chris waters here on the front
lines at South by Southwest where I just
watched Dave and Evan play Mortal Kombat
with their guitars ah dudes modal combat
what why did you do this why so for me
was you know I had always been
interested in video games it's a kid you
know I grew up you know like most of it
were NES and SNES and then I was always
a guitarist and then it's at a certain
point I took some music technology
classes and one of them was hacking
technology and then once I learned how
kind of you could reverse-engineer
things and how MIDI worked and how you
know soundtracking work I was like oh
well I could probably play a video game
with my guitar and who doesn't want to
do that because you can just combine two
really things that are awesome
absolutely so you so how did you
actually do it give us like the the
overview the layman's terms here of how
it all works yeah so basically we have
custom software on our mac computer not
it could be any kind of computer but
that's why I happen to have we're always
looking for and sponsor us yes yeah on
our level level but it's essentially
looks for certain pitches and then based
on the game like if we want high notes
to trigger punches which looks really
well then it's like an if then say if
certain pitch then output punch and
there's a lot of home-brewed technology
between that and the system but that's
essentially what what happens it looks
for pitches or volume or certain chords
yeah we play like an ascending like
major scale it'll move the character
forward we do it backwards in music
character back we strong like the
character will jump and if we play
really really fast you play pastor
tonight we really really fast then like
the character will go after each other
so it's one of those we try to use banks
of moves on our fingerboard only have
six strings and each string is it being
individually channeled into the system
so it's watching each one of our strings
in real time so it's really quite fun so
what's a favorite game you have going
currently that's
tough one so I really like pong it's so
simple and one relation it's you know
like just that one one one relaxing I
mean but obviously Mortal Kombat is like
we couldn't do it we could do a show
without pong maybe but we can do it with
that yeah it's our flagship piece I mean
we started that back at like we played
that at nyu december two thousand four
she's december two thousand so are too
long yes well if you're going to be
doing it for a little bit longer what's
the dream game to get into your modal
combat systems so that's kind of like
asking what should we do next so these
are the games here I think there's two
things they work really well in their
games to really like Big Buck Hunter was
one that we actually have working which
I really like but unfortunately it broke
before we got here tsa modal combat
they're like cool wires creating more
like oh we have pieces of it thank you
but I think maybe guitar craft it may be
around the corner you know it builds
building something together like
creating a piece while creating a
building virtually it could be really
cool will look like you guys are having
a lot of fun on stage thanks for showing
it off here good luck in your quest for
guitar craft thank you cheers very cool
thank you
you